bonsoir nouvelle édition du 7 8 sur tv
fil 78 en direct entre 18 et 19 heures
nous allons faire le point sur
l'actualité du département aujourd'hui
11 septembre nous verrons notamment
comment s'est passée la rentrée des
étudiants étrangers à l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
ils viennent du monde entier dans le
cadre des changes ils sont près d'une
centaine pour ce premier semestre qui
débute bonsoy céline peigne et c'est
bienvenu sur ce plateau vous êtes la
directrice adjointe du département des
études françaises donc de l'université
de versailles saint quentin et une
université qui a donc fait le choix de
s'ouvrir à l'international c'est la
politique officielle ait eu un
changement de présidence il ya pas
longtemps
c'est un des axes majeurs du nouveau
président absolument c'est une démarche
qui a été amorcée il ya plusieurs années
déjà et qui est entérinée par la
politique du nouveau président
d'université et que nous rejoignons avec
grand plaisir puisque nous travaillons à
l'accueil de plus de 100 étudiants
chaque année à l'université et ça semble
plutôt bien effectivement fonctionner
les étudiants se pressent pour venir à
cette université on va en parler dans un
instant c'est une peignée vous restez
avec nous et puis pour évoquer cette
rentrée des étudiants étrangers
également alice gastines bon soir à une
soirée free alors vous êtes allé les
voir ces étudiants lors d'un des
séminaires lors d'une des réunions qui
était organisé et vous avez voulu savoir
comment ils s'organisaient mais pour le
logement
ça c'est un point important le logement
ou le sait c'est difficile pour tous
pour les étudiants encore plus
et oui parce qu'en fait sur l'université
versailles saint quentin il n'ya que
1000 places disponibles 1 alors qu'il ya
dix-huit mille étudiants et les
étudiants étrangers qui sont environ
2400 peine à trouver un logement quand
il arrive à vos côtés maxime le maine
pour soir malgré un bon soir et le ferez
vous êtes là monsieur environnement de
la rédaction et oui on va pas parler
d'étudiants des étudiants avec vous a
plutôt parlé des résidences
universitaires ça rejoint un petit peu
le sujet tout de même mais une résidence
entièrement en bois en bois exactement
le critère vous savez que sur cette
chaîne mon boulot c'est de vous faire
découvrir des choses un peu particulière
et là en l'occurrence est une résidence
universitaire complètement en bois qui
est construite à versailles 60 logements
je voudrais bien bu chez mon sujet
j'espère bien vous signez vous m'avez de
la mer
bûcher ce sujet en deux mots mais fait
peur et on va en savoir un petit peu
plus dans une demi heure avec cette page
environnement de maxime qui est très en
forme ce soir on va déjà regarder le
sujet que vous avez réalisé sur place
sur cette résidence universitaire
entièrement en bois reportage bienvenue
à la fresque une résidence universitaire
versaillaise de 60 logements
actuellement en construction implantée
aux abords de l'université versailles
saint quentin
sa caractéristique est d'être construite
principalement en bois
la plateforme elle elle est réalisée en
béton parce qu'elle serve as her
structurellement réaliser certains
porte-à-faux certaines figures
architectural après au dessus de cette
plate forme dont convient tout
simplement faire un peu comme avec des
capes là pour les jeux d'enfants
organisé des enfants et voile de façade
on posait plancher par dessus les
capelains en gros et puis on élève comme
ça quatre étages du bâtiment
on a été je pense longtemps bloqué dans
la construction bois parce qu'on n'y
voyait des éléments fragiles on avait
peur du feu on avait et caetera et
s'aperçoit que techniquement on a
répondu à beaucoup de réponses à dessus
on a des bâtiments qui sont pas moins
résistants au feu quelquefois mais mieux
on a des bâtiments qui sont largement si
solide on a on a un confort
naturellement en matière d'isolation
qu'on n'avait pas obligatoirement avec
certains types de construction autre
avantage le chantier permet de faire
fonctionner des entreprises françaises
spécialisées dans la filière bois
chaque appartement mesure environ 20
mètres carrés on y retrouve une entrée
avec kitchenette une chambre et une
salle de bains accessibles aux personnes
en situation de handicap
le chauffage se fait par le sol
l'étudiant peut le régler via un
thermostat
coût total de l'opération un peu plus de
5 millions d'euros
fin des travaux prévue pour la rentrée
2013 il s'agit d'une première expérience
à versailles si elle s'avère positive la
ville n'exclut pas de construire
d'autres bâtiments de ce type sous
réserve de trouver les terrains
nous allons revenir sur l'arrivée à
l'université de versailles-saint-quentin
de 95 étudiants étrangers pour suivre
les cours de ce premier semestre dans le
cadre des échanges internationaux ils
viennent du monde entier pour suivre ses
cours il témoigne du rayonnement de
l'université illinoise dans le monde
c'est une peignée donc à la directrice
adjoint du département d'études
françaises de l'université de versailles
saint quentin
ces étudiants sont arrivés il ya pas
très longtemps en france et ils sont
chouchoutés vous organiser des
séminaires pour eux comment s'est passée
leur accueil ces derniers jours
absolument non qui sont arrivés depuis
une semaine pour les plus ce qui arrive
le plus tôt et ils peuvent arriver
encore jusqu'au mois d'octobre donc les
actes du monde entier et nous les
accueillons aussi dans les conditions
les meilleures possibles en leur
proposant un séminaire d'intégration
avant la rentrée universitaire afin
qu'ils puissent se faire des amis
perfectionne un peu leur français
connaître quelques courses initié un peu
à la vie académique qu on a un peu dans
la culture ducati française et donc être
prêt pour démarrer de rentrer dans les
meilleurs conditions puisque la rentrée
officielle pour tous les étudiants ce
sera plutôt mois d'octobre là ils sont
entrés en avance effectivement pour être
entre eux déjà et prendre le contact
avec cette université découvrir un
nouvel environnement est ce qu'ils sont
rassurés ils ont l'air plutôt
enthousiastes ils arrivent pas dire
forcément rassuré on essaie de les
rassurer qu'ils ont que faire se peut en
leur donnant toutes les clés nécessaires
pour qu'ils deviennent autonomes très
très vite et qu'ils puissent s'épanouir
dans l'environnement universitaire de
saint quentin
alors vous êtes en charge des études
françaises forcément est-ce qu'il parle
bien le français
ils peuvent arriver à tout niveau donc
nous accueillons des étudiants qui sont
grands débutants c'est à dire qu'ils
n'ont pas de compétences développées
dans la langue que l'on accompagne vers
une
une utilisation du français jusqu'à des
étudiants qui ont des niveaux très
avancé et donc qui veulent intégrer un
une licence un master voire un doctorat
à l'université ça veut dire que lors du
séminaire déjà sur les premiers jours de
la semaine dernière ils ont eu quelques
cours de français notions de français en
tout cas absolument voir des cours
d'initiation à la vie académique
française pour se familiariser avec la
prise de notes les types de commentaires
ou de devoir qui peuvent être demandées
dans le cadre d'un cursus universitaire
leur avis justement on disait tout à
l'heure au début de cette émission vous
les avez vu ces étudiants vous les avez
senti rassuré alors je suis tombé sur
des étudiants notamment en étudiant
argentin qui est en soi un doctorat en
histoire de l'art qui parle en français
voilà courant mais aussi par sur un
étudiant lituaniens qui vraiment ne
comprenait absolument rien en français
et c'est vrai que je les observais dans
l'amphithéâtre moi il était un petit peu
voilà perdus
forcément face à toutes ces informations
on va regarder ensemble ce sujet un qui
fait le point sur la rentrée de ses
étudiants étrangers argentine ukraine
lituanie allemagne royaume uni
c'est la rentrée pour ses étudiants à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
certains resteront un semestre d'autres
une année les étudiants qu'on vient
d'accueillir ce sont des étudiants qui
viennent dans le cadre de programmes des
changes
c'est à terme des échanges avec des
universités qui sont partenaires de l'ue
véhicules les autres étudiants étrangers
vient s'inscrire dans des diplômes on
soit 95 nouveaux venus sur 2400
étudiants étrangers choix des cours
carte d'étudiant assurance maladie
l'installation peut vite se transformer
en un parcours du combattant
à commencer par la recherche d'un
logement ça difficile je suis en train
de trouver un monologue une chambre je
ne sais pas mais c'est difficile pour
moi les difficultés parfois c'est la
langue parce que parfois leur niveau de
français est insuffisant pour pouvoir
suivre les cours qui sont donnés en
français pour la majorité des cas après
la difficulté majeure c'est le logement
pas se cacher qu'il ya quand même
quelques difficultés pour les
actionnaires entre le joint de la même
façon que pour les étudiants français
d'ailleurs mais bon un service logement
qui est très actif qui est qui a été
ouvert il n'y a pas très longtemps donc
il décède un maximum comme vous l'avez
vu on a distribué une liste pour des
étudiants qui seraient en difficulté
encore aujourd'hui pour le trouver un
logement
l'université de versailles saint quentin
compte dix-huit mille étudiants et près
de 1400 enseignants chercheurs elle a
passé 230 accords de partenariat avec
des universités à travers le monde alors
c'est une peignée on voyait dans ce
reportage ans cet étudiant argentin dont
je parlais sebastian qui parle très bien
français mais bon à ses côtés d'autres
étudiants ne parle presque pas français
alors comment vous faites face vous à
ses étudiants dans les niveaux sont très
diverses et variées vous proposer
plusieurs niveaux de cours
absolument nous avons de préparer une
offre qui soit de manière à accommoder
la gamme la plus large possible de
compétences en français des étudiants
donc qui viennent du monde entier
puisque comme on l'a dit dans le
reportage nous avons des conventions
avec une grande partie des régions du
monde qui discute avec la france et nous
accueillons donc des étudiants de tout
contexte linguistique culturelle et avec
toute compétence de france est donc pour
ce faire nous avons à l'heure actuelle
si des eu de préparation aux français
donc c'est pas seulement la langue mais
c'est aussi tout l'univers culturel
francophone que l'on travaille avec eux
que l'on développe afin de
l'universitaire des diplômes
universitaires excusez-moi diplôme
universitaire pour les accueillir du
niveau
en débutant au niveau très avancé avec
tout le panel de compétences qu'il est
entre les deux et ces étudiants ils
viennent tous n'aime pas ce qu'on dit il
parle pas très bien français mais c'est
plutôt en europe ils viennent de plus
loin à y viennent d' absolument du monde
entier pas venir d'inde de chine
d'argentine de de tous les pays
européens et aura également
affectivement en préparant cette
émission nous a expliqué du côté de
l'université qui savait tendance même à
un peu plus équilibrées même s'ils
viennent majoritairement encore
d'europe1 forcément les liens
privilégiés avec la france mais il ya
des pays d'asie aussi sont de plus en
plus représentées et c'est plutôt
positif parce que ça permette d'absorber
aussi le le problème de la crise
et forcément la crise touche tout le
monde même les étudiants et en europe
des étudiants espagnols des étudiants
italiens destitué en grec c'est très
compliqué de venir en france donc il ya
de plus en plus de deux pays d'asie qui
sont représentées notamment sur ses sur
ses différentes filières alors pourquoi
vient-il tout simplement aussi en france
qu'est ce qui les attire en france
l'étudiant qui viennent donc de très
loin parfois exactement donc on va les
écouter ils vont me répondre dans leur
langue pour le coup même si certains par
les français dans le reportage qu'on va
regarder on les écoute et colloques et à
qui elle parce qu'ici les relations
internationales et l'université sont
très bien et j'ai choisi versailles et
car c'était la meilleure opportunité
mélo mais les jeux aucune ya surtout
parce que j'aime la langue française les
français et bien sûr paris parce que
paris est une ville très belle et parce
qu'il y avait eu fils et beaucoup
d'autres sont intéressants se sont même
spécialisés en master
j'aime la france j'aime les français
parce que j'ai étudié le français et
j'aime la culture française
en fait j'avais l'opportunité d'étudier
à vienne ou à pavie j'ai choisi paris
pour sa culture et ses grandes voix l'a
fait pas rien marche à plein régime l'un
dans le micro trottoir qu'on a réalisée
à l'université de versailles saint
quentin en yvelines versailles c'est à
côté de paris est paris ça fait rêver
mes étudiants oui je pense que
l'université de versailles saint quentin
a su tirer parti des représentations
très positive et constructive dont
bénéficie la france et la langue
française plus largement pour proposer
une offre qui est vraiment ouverte et
qui exploite le côté culturel et
l'immersion qu'offrent les diplômes
universitaires adressé aux études
internationales et du coup vers quelles
filières plus tôt il se tourne donc vous
avez pu rencontrer alors c'est très très
vaste il y à 2 2 profils d'étudiants
principaux ce qui viennent étudier le
français et s'immerger dans la culture
française et développer leurs
compétences en matière de francophonie
et de langues et qui parfois rejoindre
le second groupe qui lui concerne les
étudiants qui viennent intégrer un
cursus licence master doctorat à leurs
niveaux et dans tous les domaines qu'ils
peuvent re qu'ils peuvent suivre déjà
dans leur pays en termes d'études et
c'est assez facile lorsqu'on est
étudiant à l'étranger de venir en france
suivre des études
alors malheureusement ça dépend aussi
des visas et des passeports qu'ils ont
en main au niveau de l'accueil d'une
fois qu'ils peuvent venir en france on
fait le maximum pour que leur vie
quotidienne et universitaire soit
festivités à la vie quotidienne aussi
c'est forcément se loger alice est il
facile de se loger lorsqu'on est
étudiant on y vient et non il ya quand
même beaucoup difficultés ont rappelé
ces chiffres en début d'émission
seulement 1000 places 1 pour les
dix-huit mille étudiants de l'ensemble
de l'université il ya 2400 étudiants
étrangers donc parmi les étudiants que
j'ai rencontrés on va ré écouter donc
sebastian qui nous expliquiez argentin
qui nous explique les difficultés qu'il
a pour trouver un logement
c'est difficile
on trouvait un chameau
mais c'est difficile pour moi est dans
le même cas on va écouter cet étudiant
lituaniens qui faute de logement habitat
1h15 de transport de l'université
c'est difficile car il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui ne parlent pas anglais
c'est très dur de trouver un appartement
je n'ai pas pu avoir de logements
universitaires
je vis à 1h15 d'ici et c'est pas facile
c'est une peignée est ce que les
difficultés à trouver un logement
peuvent handicaper les étudiants dans
leurs études
je ne saurais dire si ça les handicaps
dans leurs études mais il est vrai que
de la part du département des langues et
des études internationales de nombreux
projets pourrait être facilitée si
l'offre en matière de logement pouvait
être diversifiée et a grandi quel genre
de projet d nous proposons des stages
pour les la formation des enseignants
qui sont déjà en poste à l'étranger nous
proposons des stages plus ou moins court
à des étudiants internationaux en fait
sur proposition aussi et sur leur envie
de nous proposons sur mesure des
formations en fonction des besoins à
l'international et si nous pouvions
accueillir toutes les personnes qui sont
intéressées par le fait travailler avec
nous nous pourrions développer une offre
beaucoup plus riche je vais vous laisser
conclure a dit sur cet aspect du
logement rappeler quelques chiffres
cette page là mais juste ou même une
question l'entente du cet étudiant
dernier étudiant il fait une heure
quinze de trajet pour venir à
l'université
bon forcément vous allez me dire ya
beaucoup d'étudiants qui font 1h15 mais
quand on vient de l'étranger qu'il faut
aussi s'acclimater et qu'on fait 1h15
forcément la scolarité en pâtit est ce
qu'il ya des choses spécifiques qui sont
mis en place pour les étudiants vous y
prêter une attention plus grande à ces
étudiants là disons qu'on est les on
essaie de les former à être autonome et
flexible et de s'adapter aux conditions
ça fait partie malheureusement puisqu'on
ne peut pas dans l'immédiat pas liés à
ce type de questions on espère qu'ils
trouvent un intérêt autrement mais le
savent alors ce qu'il vous arrive en
france que forcément vous savent pas
forcément puisque tout ce qui est de
l'ordre de l'implicite culturelle n'est
pas une évidence à l'international aussi
bien quand ils viennent en france que
quand nous nous allons à l'étranger
parfois il ya des allant de soi
déconstruire on essaie de les
accompagner dans cette démarche là en
espérant bien sûr de cette question des
logements puissent aussi les séminaires
vous avez organisé depuis la semaine
dernière sert aussi à ça pas seulement
alors si on démarre dans le français
mais aussi pour les acclimater voilà et
devant ces difficultés donc liés au
logement
l'université a mis en place l'année
dernière
un véritable service un dédié au
logement étudiant car le nombre
d'étudiants étrangers aussi est en
augmentation
donc on l'a dit le nombre de places
disponibles sur le territoire
l'université c'est 1000 lits donc
plusieurs plots le projet sont en cours
1 sur l'agglomération de de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines d'abord à
maurepas en septembre 2013 1610 places
devraient être disponibles un autre
projet pour septembre 2014 à guyancourt
qui devrait offrir 147 places et puis
deux autres projets à un montini donc
dans le siège du vélodrome du chantier
du vélodrome trois résidences
respectivement 380 et 120 places et
enfin à elancourt 160 places serait créé
d'ici 2014 mercialys
un dernier mot avec vaut également pour
conclure sur ce plateau dédié aux
étudiants étrangers qui font leur pré
rentrée en ce moment du côté de
l'université de versailles-saint-quentin
ya pas de prérequis forcément français
pour venir à l'université on est bien
d'accord ça veut dire qu'un étudiant
étranger peut venir en france et faire
des études sans suivre un seul cours de
français et repartir sans avoir appris
le français
disons qu'on lui souhaite d'avoir les
contacts sociaux culturels et
linguistiques qui font qu'il va
développer une certaine compétence en
français ça voudrait dire que sa vie
sociale est riche et que son quotidien
est agréable on a besoin d'être re je
pense pour faire des études
donc il ya quand même de fortes chances
que que sept étudiants et des notions de
français on leur propose également un
même pour les étudiants qui suivent des
cursus qui n'ont rien à voir avec la
langue française
on leur propose de suivre plusieurs
cours assez diversifiée qui soit plutôt
linguistiques culturelles ou basés sur
des matières à contenu donc on
on met à leur disposition cette offre là
pour qu'ils puissent suivre leurs études
tout en se faisant plaisir et en
développant des compétences entre
forcément faut que ça se passe bien pour
eux durant leur séjour s'est ensuite ce
sont des ambassadeurs de l'université
tout à fait pour laura de l'université
on imagine c'est important merci céline
payer de l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin d'être venu sur
le plateau
merci également à l'iss pour ses
différentes précision nous allons
poursuivre le 7,8 à présent avec un
point sur les principaux titres de
l'actualité de ce 11 septembre une
résidence universitaire sur quatre
étages entièrement construite en bois 7
à versailles 60 logements sont
construits de manière écologique le
chantier a débuté il ya six mois
plus de détails dans un quart d'heure
maintenant avec maxime le maine et le
rendez-vous de l'environnement du mardi
le lycée jean vilar de plaisir participe
au goncourt des lycéens seuls deux
établissements en ile-de-france ont été
sélectionnés les élèves de première
littéraire ont maintenant deux mois pour
lire 11 livres trois d'entre eux et leur
enseignante vont me rejoindre citant
quelques instants si vous cherchez un
bureau une étagère ou même une voiture à
moindre coût rendez vous sur le site
internet de l'agglomération de saint
quentin qui mettait aux enchères
certains de ses biens à la vente aura
lieu à la fin de la semaine et puis une
histoire romantique également dans
l'actualité du jour est celle du couple
d'espère qui vient de célébrer ses noces
de platine 70 ans de mariage
reportage à découvrir dans quelques
instants